you know if the right person watches
this video something crazy can happen I
may explain to your wife world cup is
finished with no one's watching it
anymore France won the World Cup right
and someone asked me so Pat what was
your biggest takeaway from the World Cup
I said look you got 7 billion people
that watch this sport 7 billion people
we even got people at the Home Office
still playing soccer and everybody's
gone right 7 billion people follows a
sport France wins the whole thing think
about it this way Luka Modric wins the
golden ball ballon there or right and
then you have embarked from France who
becomes the youngest player teenager
since Pele to score a goal in the finals
which is insane but I want you to think
about it this way look at it this way
every sports magazine every newspaper
every internet website is going to write
about those two names Luka Modric
everyone's gonna know who he is
em Bop a everyone in the world knows who
use a 19 year old kid is now hero that
people didn't know around the world what
does this mean to you look every
industry every decade has a new Imbaba
say one more time every industry every
decade has a new Imbaba every industry
every decade has a new Luka Modric every
industry someone around the world today
has made a decision to be the greatest
realtor in that country
someone in the world today has made a
decision to become the best businessman
of that country for the next decade
someone in the world today has made a
decision to be the best actor the best
producer the best director the best
something someone's made a decision and
guess what they think about it for
morning tonight they dream about it they
fantasize about it they sleep writing
about it all over the wall they tell
their families it's gonna happen one day
they tell themselves in front of mirror
it's gonna happen one day
until it becomes a reality everybody see
the right person watching this I said at
the beginning the right person watching
this your industry is looking for a name
Bobby your industry is looking for a
locale you have an opportunity every
decades somebody rises up no one knows
who it is only the person that's going
through that process
no suitors if that's you you got to put
your head down get to work out work out
last out strategize out improve
everybody in the marketplace five 10
years later they're gonna call you TM
Bobby De Luca of your industry but by
the way as much work as you think it is
as much improvement as you think it is
it's ten times we a lot of long nights
where everybody's home you're still
training you're still selling you still
working you're still getting better many
many nights like that
but I can't wait to meet the embodies
the Lukas of all these different
industries in the world hopefully to be
used
[Music]